[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos suscriptores nos habéis pedido
este vídeo y la verdad no me extraña la
república de china más conocida como
taiwán es uno de los países con una
situación desde el punto de vista
político y diplomático más extraña y
controvertida de todo el planeta me
explico amigos en el momento en que
publicamos este vídeo está igual está
reconocida formalmente por tan solo 20
países en todo el mundo
y ojo algunos de ellos tan peculiares
como el vaticano o tuvalú o suazilandia
por cierto los países más importantes
que siguen reconociendo a taiwán están
en latinoamérica son el salvador
nicaragua guatemala honduras paraguay y
la república dominicana pero la verdad
veremos por cuánto tiempo lo siguen
haciendo
luego entenderéis por qué digo esto el
caso es que a pesar de todo taiwán ha
conseguido meterse en el club de los
países más ricos y más libres de todo el
mundo
cuenta con un poderoso ejército de más
de 300 mil hombres muy bien equipado y
es una de las puntas de lanza de eeuu en
el sudeste asiático
pero qué es lo que está ocurriendo en
taiwán que podemos esperar de este
pequeño país estas son algunas de las
preguntas que vamos a contestar en este
vídeo pero antes echemos la mirada atrás
y veamos dónde empezó todo
[Música]
la gran separación china
la peculiar situación que hoy vive
taiwán tiene su origen en la gran guerra
civil china que tuvo lugar entre 1927 y
1949 esta guerra enfrentó a las fuerzas
conservadoras del partido nacionalista
chino liderado por chiang kai-shek con
las fuerzas del partido comunista chino
liderado por mao tse tung pues bien el
día 10 de diciembre de 1949 cayó siendo
la última gran ciudad china en manos de
los nacionalistas la guerra había
terminado y los comunistas se habían
llevado el gato al agua' poco antes de
caerse en un avión que transportaba al
líder nacionalista
chiang kai-shek partió rumbo a taiwán la
última provincia bajo su control junto a
él se refugiaron en taiwán dos millones
de personas y los restos que quedaban
del ejército nacionalista
de esta forma taipei la ciudad más
grande de la isla pasó a convertirse en
la capital de la república de china
desde entonces aunque mal trato de
apoderarse de la isla en alguna que otra
ocasión taiwán recibió el apoyo
de quién si de eeuu que siguió
reconociendo al gobierno de taipei como
el gobierno legítimo de toda china hasta
nada menos que en 1979
como curiosidad cabe decir que la fuerza
aérea de taiwán fue la única del mundo
junto a la de eeuu que operó de manera
asidua los célebres aviones espía u2
su misión era vigilar a la china de mao
la mismísima fía dirigía los operativos
sin embargo en esos años eeuu estaba
tratando de ganarse el favor de pekín
para como decir hacer una especie de
operación pinza contra la unión
soviética como por cierto ya nos contó
alberto aquí en visual político el 21 de
febrero de 1972 se produjo uno de los
acontecimientos más importantes de las
últimas décadas ese día richard nixon
llegó a pekín al final del vídeo os dejo
el enlace y también en la descripción
pues bien el caso es que en 1979 el por
aquel entonces presidente de eeuu jimmy
carter decidió establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con pekín y eso supuso
dejar de reconocer como homólogo al
gobierno de la república china esto es
al gobierno de taipei veréis taiwán
nunca declaró su independencia durante
años el gobierno de taipei siguió
considerándose como el gobierno legítimo
de toda china y claro diplomáticamente
un país sólo puede tener un gobierno
reconocido
así es como surgió la política de una
sola china que hoy es seguida por
washington y por la mayoría de países
del mundo un giro que por cierto le
supuso a taiwán perder su puesto en la
onu y prácticamente todos los organismos
internacionales
[Música]
eso sí en eeuu siguió comprometido con
la seguridad de la isla y en ese mismo
año en 1979 el congreso estadounidense
aprobó la llamada acta de relaciones con
taiwán un documento que se reserva la
opción por ejemplo de velar por la
seguridad y la defensa de la isla algo
que eeuu ha hecho desde entonces
[Música]
pero como os decía al comenzar el vídeo
nada de esto ha conseguido evitar que
taiwán protagonizó una de las más
grandes historias de éxito económico y
social
[Música]
el gran rugido del tigre en los años 50
taiwán era un lugar muy pobre con una
economía muy rudimentaria donde casi
todo lo que vendían al mundo era
productos tan básicos como azúcar o
arroz pero claro esto no era suficiente
la isla necesitaba recursos para
garantizar su supervivencia y los
necesitaba de forma urgente
en ese momento el gobierno pensó que
tenía que lograr que los empresarios de
la isla pudieran vender productos
industriales por todo el mundo y qué
mejor manera de lograrlo que abrirse al
mundo y favorecer el ahorro si ahorro
para poder invertir primero hay que
conseguir los recursos que hacen falta
dicho y hecho el gobierno de la isla
pronto comenzó a eliminar prácticamente
todas las restricciones a la importación
de esa manera amigos sus empresarios
podían hacerse de forma competitiva con
todos los productos que necesitaban para
poner en marcha sus negocios y cadenas
de producción es como decirlo algo
similar a lo que hizo singapur por otro
lado la cultura del ahorro y la
seguridad jurídica hicieron que el país
tuviese una capacidad de inversión
enorme pronto las empresas comenzaron a
crecer como setas y a exportar todo tipo
de productos al resto del mundo
pues bien en la década de los 80 los
productos industriales suponían que el
90 por ciento de las exportaciones del
país
y ojo crecían de media un 30% cada año
taiwán vendía de todo al mundo
juguetes radios bicicletas calcetines de
todo y claro en esa situación como os
podéis imaginar la renta per cápita de
los taiwaneses no paraba de crecer en
apenas 30 años se multiplicó por cinco
había nacido amigos un nuevo tigre
asiático
aunque no todo el camino ha sido tan de
color de rosas taiwán no se convirtió en
una democracia hasta prácticamente los
años 90 eso sí una vez alcanza la
libertad los taiwaneses se abrazaron a
ella
[Música]
hoy taiwán es la undécima economía más
libre de todo el mundo y la tercera de
asia tan sólo por detrás de hong kong y
singapur es un país rico con un nivel de
vida bastante alto y además está en el
club de los países con más libertades
civiles de hecho amigos taiwán está a
punto de hacer historia da igual será el
primer país asiático en legalizar el
matrimonio homosexual
[Música]
como veis en la comparación con la china
continental
taiwán gana por goleada los taiwaneses
son hoy tres veces más ricos que los
chinos y mucho muchísimo más libres pero
vale a pesar de ello también hay algunas
nubes en su horizonte
[Música]
nubes en los cielos de taiwán la verdad
es que en los últimos años el país está
sufriendo algún que otro problema
de hecho en 2015 el país padeció una
pequeña recesión y desde entonces el
crecimiento económico de la isla cómo
decirlo se ha enfriado mucho llegados a
este punto hay una pregunta clara sobre
la mesa qué diantres está pasando pues
son varios los ingredientes de esta
amarga receta que está enturbiando el
presente de la isla y que también
amenaza su futuro atentos la competencia
de china y de nuevos mercados emergentes
como indonesia o vietnam la fuga de
talento el envejecimiento poblacional o
por ejemplo un sistema de pensiones
prácticamente quebrado son algunos de
los factores que han provocado que los
salarios lleven años prácticamente
congelados y que el crecimiento
económico sea muy bajo
precisamente el sistema de pensiones es
con diferencia uno de los más grandes
quebraderos de cabeza del gobierno de la
isla mira durante años las pensiones de
los trabajadores públicos fueron
infladas por motivos políticos es decir
para ganar votos y esto amigos es algo
que sale caro muy caro las pensiones
fueron tan infladas que hoy han puesto
en jaque a todo el sistema
el salario promedio mensual de un
trabajador en taiwán es de 1300 dólares
americanos por su parte la pensión de un
maestro jubilado asciende de media a
2.234 dólares un 75% más lo sabéis las
malas políticas salen carísimas pero
continuamos con la receta al siguiente
ingrediente lo podemos denominar como el
problema del 40 40 fijaos la economía
taiwanesa es muy dependiente de la
industria electrónica y del comercio con
china los productos electrónicos suponen
el 40 por ciento de todas las
exportaciones y por su parte china es el
destino para el 40 por ciento de las
exportaciones taiwanesas
y puede que te preguntes pero que tiene
todo esto de malo pues que cuando la
industria electrónica o china no van
bien pues el país lo nota y eso es
precisamente lo que ha ocurrido por
ejemplo con la desaceleración china en
los últimos años cuando la china
continental estornuda taiwán está
hospitalizada en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos y luego tal vez por encima de
todos los demás hay un problema un
problema político que afecta mucho al
país y que por ejemplo ha provocado que
la inversión extranjera en taiwán sea
bastante menor que la de los países
vecinos sabéis cuál es el temor a china
[Música]
la amenaza china este es con diferencia
el principal problema al que se enfrenta
taiwán el gobierno de pekín está
empeñado en recuperar la soberanía sobre
la isla y en sus declaraciones públicas
afirma dos cosas primero que esto
ocurrirá antes de 2.049 el año del 100
aniversario de la república popular
china y segundo que está dispuesto a
utilizar la fuerza si taiwán intenta
declararse siquiera independiente
taiwán es de facto un país independiente
la isla tiene su propio presidente
elegido por cierto democráticamente
también sus propias leyes y sus propias
fuerzas armadas sin embargo pekín no
está dispuesto a aceptar esta
posibilidad lo más que está dispuesto es
a concederle a taiwán de forma temporal
un estatus similar al de hong kong
y esto ojo es un problema un problema
grave en todas las cosas porque la
mayoría de los taiwaneses ya no sienten
ningún lazo de identidad con china
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sienten que son sencillamente ciudadanos
de un país libre que lleva ha sido
independiente casi 70 años de hecho
cuando en 2014 el anterior gobierno de
taiwán quiso acercarse demasiado a pekín
y como decirlo transigir con algunas de
sus tesis se produjo la llamada
revolución de los girasoles y cientos de
jóvenes se apostaron en el parlamento al
grito de taiwán no se venden
precisamente bajo este clima de
frustración económica y política en
enero de 2016 el partido demócrata
progresista un partido cuyas bases son
mayoritariamente independentistas ganó
las elecciones legislativas y también
las presidenciales sign when poco
cercana a pekín se convirtió así en la
primera presidenta de taiwán aunque
probablemente la economía fue el factor
decisivo en esta elección a pekín le ha
sentado fatal tanto que ha reanudado la
política de acoso y derribo contra
taiwán en lo que llevamos de 2017 el
turismo chino taiwán se ha reducido un
40%
pekín ha conseguido que dos países
panamá y santo tomé y príncipe dejen de
reconocer a taiwán y está impidiendo la
presencia de la isla en muchos foros
internacionales de momento no han tomado
represalias económicas pero en la isla
saben que esto podría suponer un duro
golpe un golpe durísimo para taiwán por
eso entre las prioridades del nuevo
gobierno está enfocarse urgentemente a
nuevo
pero puede que se estéis preguntando y
eeuu donde está en eeuu que dice de todo
esto pues de momento parece que su apoyo
a taiwán permanece intacto de hecho
recientemente el gobierno de trump ha
aprobado una nueva venta de armas a la
isla por valor de casi 1500 millones de
dólares
eeuu enfada a china con la venta de
armas a taiwán por valor de mil 420
millones de dólares y además lo más
importante ojo recientemente el poderoso
comité sobre servicios armados del
senado de eeuu aprobó con el voto
mayoritario de sus miembros tanto del
partido republicano como del partido
demócrata que los buques de la marina
puedan utilizar de forma operativa en
los puertos taiwaneses si las cámaras
finalmente aprueban esta propuesta el
cabreo de pekín va a ser de aúpa pero
que persigue washington con todo esto
pues sobre todo amigos intentar que a
pekín no se le pase por la cabeza
siquiera una invasión militar en fin así
están las cosas desde visual política
estaremos muy atentos a todo lo que
ocurra en esta pequeña pero
interesantísima isla ahora turno para ti
cuál crees que debe ser el futuro de
taiwán puedes dejarnos tu opinión en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
como siempre si el vídeo te ha resultado
interesante dale a like y no olvidéis
suscribirte al canal un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Aplausos]
[Música]